you guys got married not because you
guys were in love it was like a business
transaction we went on our first date
and we ended up talking about business
for four hours and I didn't like have
any romantic anything but I was like
she's cool and so I felt myself kind of
just like wanting to see her again I
mean I remember the next day I was like
hey I'm working all day I want to come
work with me and she said sure and so
then she just like hung out with me and
then we just both worked together and
that was kind of like the vibe of how
things started like whatever I was doing
I'd just rather do it with her and so
it's much more companionate the shared
Mission and shared values of like this
is what I want to do with my life she's
like me too I want to do big [ __ ] and
like up to that point I definitely dated
people who want to do big things but
like the types of big things they wanted
to do were different than the types of
things I wanted to do and so we weren't
Mission aligned when you want to do big
things like what do you have to go
through to get there is hard and I knew
that where I wanted to go not a lot of
people would be able to hang but like I
just knew that I was willing to go
through a lot of suffering to get there
and she was too when I lost everything I
kind of sat her down I was like like if
you leave right now like I won't blame
you she's like if I have to sleep with
you under a bridge I will that you just
like was there even though I gave her
like an outcome